hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in the last video complete with its own
quantum upload we talked a bit about how
quantum computers work and their
implications for the world but some of
you either didn't quite grasp it or
wanted a deeper more literal explanation
and I agree so I thought I'd make this
video to bring you up to speed you are
watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
the following information is from my
book new thinking I talked to some
people in my University and had someone
who actually worked with quantum
computers read over it to make sure that
it was all technically correct so from
the last video we know that quantum
computers can solve problems that would
take infinitely long in a classical
computer things such as modeling the
brain and modeling weather systems etc
but let's take a deeper look at how they
work
we covered the regular computers process
data as binary bits represented either
as a 1 or a 0 a quantum computers
equivalent data is known as quantum bits
or qubits which can exist in both 0 and
1 states at once allowing multiple
computations to happen simultaneously
these states in a particle are called
spin but there's really no need to know
what that is for the purpose of this
video this simultaneous state of both
missouri and 1 is like a kind of sweep
of probabilities called a superposition
this makes it possible to store and
manipulate vast amounts of information
with a relatively small amount of
particles so what is a qubit made from
while a normal computer spits are made
from tiny transistors a qubit can be
anything that exhibits quantum behavior
an electron an atom or even a molecule
that is if the environment is right more
on this later so I just want to solidify
why the superposition aspect is so
important as I said in the last video
our world and reality itself
is quantum in nature real-world quantum
systems can't be modelled on a classical
computer without making poor
approximations for the two simple
molecules in this example here a
classical computer is off by a factor of
70 to 200 percent think about it
modeling such a simple compound as
calcium mono fluoride makes our best
supercomputers completely useless our
current machines are so inaccurate
because the electrons in the real world
that are orbiting around these atoms are
themselves in superposition these
electrons exist in multiple states at
once and we can't model that properly
with classical computers calculating all
the possibilities is just too much for
quantum computers on the other hand can
leverage the fact that they themselves
also operate using superposition
this kind of modeling which is
impossible today will become routine
because of the sheer amount of data that
quantum computers can hold richard
fineman
who was instrumental in the very
formation of quantum physics first
proposed this concept
[Music]
to get that exponential processing speed
up the qubits must be able to
communicate the fate of all qubits are
linked together in a process called
quantum entanglement entanglement is
just a relationship between two
superposition particles the state of one
determines the state of the other so
basically all this means that in quantum
computers entanglement along with
superposition helps the system store all
possible solutions at once so what a
quantum computers good at as it turns
out as far as we know quantum computers
are good at things that have a small
input and output while having a vast
array of possibilities let's take a look
at a few examples to solidify this idea
so for modeling complex molecules the
input is the number of particles in
their starting state while the output is
what happens after a given time the
possibilities of what happens in between
that time are almost infinite another
example breaking encryption in 1994
American mathematician Peter shor of
Bell Labs found a theoretical way to use
quantum computers to break codes that
relied on the factorization of large
numbers into primes this doesn't sound
like much at first but many online
security systems from banking to
encryption rely on the principle that is
currently almost impossible to take a
very large number and figure out what
the prime factors are the best algorithm
known for classical computers uses a
number of steps that keeps increasing
exponentially until it takes a billions
of years using the algorithm by Peter
shor called Shor's algorithm a quantum
computer could perform the task in just
a number of hours in this case the input
is a single large number and the output
is how many sets of prime numbers
multiplied together to give that large
number again the possibilities here are
almost infinite one last but simpler
example finding the longest distance
between two cities in Japan the input is
the map data row distances etc it's
large but nothing that a classical
computer couldn't handle
the output is just one number the
longest distance and the possibilities
well it seems like a simple problem but
if you think about it there's an almost
infinite number of routes you can take
in fact this very class a problem is
forever unsolvable using classical
computers this class of problem is
mathematically called
an np-complete problem there are many
other real world problems of this type
from weather patterns and climate change
to boosting artificial intelligence
training from looking at patterns and
stock market data or in recordings of
brain activity not to mention gene
analysis and drug delivery as well as
many other things unlike with today's
computers finding these patterns could
become routine requiring no detailed
understanding of the subject problem and
this is what makes pontem computers so
interesting so this all sounds good but
there are still some hurdles the first
problem is due to quantum physics itself
an observer can never directly know all
the vast number of qubit states at the
same time all an observer knows is the
probability of what state the qubits
will be in the very act of observing or
measuring the overall state of the
quantum computers qubits will force the
system to decide on which state they're
in so instead of the quick trillions of
answers we can only see one and that's
another quirk of the quantum world so
how do we make this useful well the
answers that come out of quantum
computers are in the form of a
probability if you repeat the question
the answer will change slightly and the
quantum computer stay will begin to
approach the theoretical percentage or
correct answer the more times you repeat
you might ask the quantum computer
several times but getting a good answer
on the second or third attempt may still
be much faster than waiting for a
certain answer on a classical computer
so this next part is pretty crazy in
order for a quantum system to push
towards the right answer when asked
repeatedly the code must be designed so
that the qubits are likely to be in the
correct State for a given problem
hence give us the right answer
fascinatingly the quantum code is
designed to use the wave-like properties
found in particle physics to cancel out
the wrong answers and amplify the
correct answer the answer can then be
detected and viewed
the manipulation of nature through code
is called a quantum algorithm
mathematicians and scientists around the
world are on a race to build these
algorithms for when capable quantum
computers arrive so with all of this
said why don't we have powerful quantum
computers now it's mostly because of the
second problem with building the
practicality of maintaining and quantum
environment in my book I refer to qubit
is very shy divas
to be in their quantum superposition
state that is being in multiple states
at once they need to be comfortable
qubits must be free from all radiation
and kept at a temperature just above
that of absolute zero if the particle
interacts with anything the quantum
effects are scared away any slight
disturbances such as light particles
radiation or even quantum vibrations can
snap the particles out of their
superposition state this voids the
entire advantage of the machine right
now we can only achieve a quantum
superposition for a tiny fraction of a
second not long enough to carry out a
useful algorithm mastering this fragile
quantum state still remains one of the
biggest challenges for engineers and
scientists to build a practical quantum
computer so that brings us to the next
and final point how do you actually
build these things
our current quantum computer designs
consists of two main types for
construction the superconductor type and
the spin type that is these are small
particles the most popular spin method
uses single electrons within silicon to
create qubits the reason for this is
that the infrastructure for nanoscale
silicon components is already
established so it makes economic sense
to just leverage what we already have
for a new kind of competing these
electrons within the silicon are called
quantum dots only several nanometers in
size they can operate at slightly higher
temperatures making them more stable
research on this method only started to
pick up in 2017 the older more
established qubit uses a metallic
superconductor to create a quantum state
superconductor qubits defy the
misconception that the strange quantum
effects are impossible for larger
objects this is not strictly true the
way we get large objects to produce
quantum states is by letting the
material reach that fragile Divac state
this is done by subjecting them to a
super cold of vacuum environment the
result is a cubit that's visible to the
naked eye the most popular method is a
super cold metallic ring almost at
Absolute Zero at these temperatures
electrons can flow around forever
without ever bumping into anything
strange is still all these electrons
flow clockwise but at the same time all
the electrons also flow counterclockwise
if the clockwise flow is read as one and
the counterclockwise flow is read as a
zero it's essentially a superposition
qubit a superconductor method is Howdy
way of IBM and Google quantum computers
work so to round out let's take a look
at a few achievements so right now the
best quantum computer we have is using
the quantum dot method so most of those
qubits are used for error detection on
the roads building a quantum computer
MIT scientists have reported the
discovery of a new triple photon form of
light an Australian team has set the
record for the most accurate one qubit
gate in a silicon quantum dot they had a
remarkable accuracy of 99.9 six percent
and also many other companies are
joining in the quantum race from
startups all the way to establish names
like Honeywell IBM also wants a
commercial quantum computer in as little
as 3 years somewhere does this all leave
us
so as concluded in the last video
quantum computers hold great promise but
it's still going to be multiple decades
before we have a meaningful machine and
I'll say that when the first
breakthrough is start to happen we'll
enter a hype cycle where the media and
everyone picks it up thinking that
quantum computers are around the corner
but they're just not ready yet and
expectations will probably follow before
the real breakthrough is actually start
to happen in a couple of decades
[Music]
hopefully this video answered a lot of
your questions from the last video if
you do want to know more about this and
other technology all the way from the
Industrial Revolution to quantum
computers and AI be sure to check out my
book the audio book version is also
available in the description below so
that wraps up the video thanks for
watching it might take a few lessons to
process all of this information
but once you do it becomes clear just
how amazing this topic of quantum
computers is it's one of the most
fascinating topics I've ever come across
anyway this has been - gogo and you've
been watching cold fusion and I'll catch
you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]